d'abord c'est bien que le sénat puisse
s'exprimer sur le discours de politique
générale du premier ministre que ses
seins dans une assemblée même si ça n'en
porte pas évidemment démission du
gouvernement si un vote contre puisque
la constitution n'a pas prévu ça mais
c'est bien qu'on veut dans une
déclaration de politique générale le
sénat soit traité comme l'assemblée
nationale puisse exprimer par son vote
ce qu'ils pensent du discours de
politique générale je rappelle la
situation à laquelle nous sommes au
sénat 23 sénateurs
lrm qui se réclament de la majorité et
au sol nous sommes à 71 ça veut dire
qu'un certain nombre de gens qui ont
voulu montrer avec on est écouté
discours du président manu rées du
président marseille du président rockets
qui ont exprimé un certain nombre de
choses qui allaient dans le bon sens
pour eux des choses sur lequel il
fallait aller plus loin c'est je le
prends comme un signe d'ouverture d'un
certain nombre de gens qui disent on
veut la réussite du pays on veut qu'ils
aient des rassemblements qui puisse
s'opérer dans l'intérêt du pays on veut
être dans une stratégie du dépassement
ce qu'a dit le premier ministre et c'est
bien qu'on puisse franchir c'est celle
là je salue aussi ceux qui ont fait le
choix de l'abstention qui est une
position de réserve qu'on peut
comprendre personne ne demande à
personne ne renonce à ce qui les
commercialisent et pas moi ça vous
permet d'avoir un petit peu donc le
décompte des troupes et donc 71 des
jeunes en jeûnant régime monte personne
il ya des gens qui ont exprimé dans leur
vote le vote c'était la confiance ou pas
la confiance à la déclaration de
politique générale du premier ministre
c'est à dire de plus c'est un acte de
confiance et c'est important dans la vie
politique quand des gens expriment un
acte de confiance et c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait aujourd'hui mais moi je n'en
régiment de personnes je ne je ne ferme
personne sur ce groupe je regrette que
dans certains groupes on était dans une
stratégie un peu de l'isolément en
disant il faut voter contre parce qu'on
est dans l'opposition non on peut être
dans l'opposition on peut être un
républicain on peut penser qu'il ya des
choses qui vont dans le bon sens et que
ont fait crédit à telle ou telle quelle
que soit son origine pour essayer de
faire avancer le payer donc c'est un
acte positif et d'ouverture qui a été
exprimé par beaucoup de sénateurs jeu
j'y vois comme un bon chez nous pas tant
au service de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale en avant une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale mais aussi un
signe d'ouverture de volonté de
travailler ensemble
assemblée et sénat d'ailleurs tous les
sénateurs l'ont bien dit ils gardent
leur liberté pour les futurs projets de
loi qu'elle vous savez dans la douleur
sans nom mais dans la vie politique on a
besoin de gens libres a besoin de gens
libres et qui pousse c'est ce qui s'est
exprimé aussi aujourd'hui l'intérêt du
pays et moi je trouve que c'est toujours
une bonne nouvelle en démocratie